peux tu commences
[Musique]
il
giresse
m
la mairie
le china
les autres extraits on va les faire pour
esprits comme ça on pourra en faire
beaucoup plus je vais prendre moi c'est
ma deuxième extrait beaucoup plus connu
celui d'un violent et les anciens n'a
pas eu d'exode ensemble avec oman soit
tu cambrésis jean-claude
la donner
mieux
robin et de monde
[Musique]
séguin
tout billet enfant
à des communes
nat 2
comme ça au clair de lune
la france suit
les invasive yves gentil comme ça des
nuits entières pour des milliardaires
américains c'est d'abord aux abords et
toutes ses chansons j'avais déjà un bon
goût en réunion sans la musique en
dessus de voyous leaf que nos colonnes
jean claude ici tu y as oui je suis
toujours très fort tant qu on
l'applaudît pas jean claude trichet a
laissé de bons souvenirs mais tout va
changer tout seul pendant d'écouté je
travaille un peu c'est à l'angle
américain
enfin
j'ai déjà ce marché se
de suite
dans notre pays même temps
c'est
le hippisme
la rue en général rester
ces ricains aux lotois en sauna
c'était mon huitième et non et non
'nos tué parce que je sais
tu as vite
après c'était un truc différent de
chansons américaines avec moi mais alors
cette fois ci pour la chanter en
français chanson bien chanter en
français bbc arabic et on essayait en
français non sire en disent adieu
et comment
feyzin
m
sacha distel la méchante et de demain
ce serait si loi
et b
ça faisait longtemps comme ça l'homme a
passé quelque chose de plus anciens
peut-être pas tout vendre deux absents
même 2010 n'en parlait pas en parle de
la vie commence
chan
chiant
/
jana
[Musique]
m
jana
[Musique]
je ne savais pas
facile
[Musique]
s'envoler ce pays
ce temps là
oh
plus de 100
m
la beta de mag plan nano
je suis pas
patrimoniaux de sens car ça paie
j'ai pris ma copine
phase one
tarifs entre le landeron
bamako
amado et db ans de ça comme ça
ce qui se met ainsi fin aux méthodes
on s'en va
alléluia
je
c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]